we were shown inside georges lugar
laboratory which detects and prevents
the spread of dangerous diseases but
pro-kremlin media claim it spreads
disease experimenting on humans with
cancer the Zika virus killer mosquitoes
and plagues of stink bugs I asked the
laboratories director whether there was
any truth to these narratives but we are
not making sicker virus in this but the
laboratory is the the level of the
laboratory is so high that we can
diagnose here the zika ebola creamier
congo and many many infection diseases
no killers Bansky we may think this
virus is here no mama rated stinkbug
coming from the libyan laboratory what
the marmorated stink bug ah I'm not a
scientist but what I have been seeing
here suggests that this laboratory is
exactly what the Georgian government
says it is the Russian claims that
what's going on at the lugar lab is far
more sinister haven't been supported by
any hard evidence Facebook investigators
made the startling claim that Georgia's
governing party had adopted Russian
style disinformation to discredit its
opponents Facebook shut down dozens of
fake news accounts and pages government
officials deny the allegations but
fact-checking organizations say
political groups in Georgia increasingly
employ such tactics more than a hundred
Facebook pages connected to far-right
organizations spread anti-western
narratives and there in Georgian
language the Alliance of patriots party
which came third in elections in 2016
claims homosexuality is a Western
disease and that NATO membership had
caused another war with Russia you're
fighting a losing battle is that how you
would characterize it yes because of
what we see
groups of these people is increasing the
audience number is increasing until
they're working we're recording 80 so in
this case we have at least the reason to
admit this and to start working on that
issue like a virus disinformation in
Georgia is spreading faster than it can
be contained robbing Forestier walker al
jazeera Tbilisi